well famous food streets eats is coming
to resorts world
this summer blending eastern and western
asian food culture the 16 stall
culinary marketplace will incorporate
authentic street food
and cuisine from all over the world
brought to you by the zoo group
singapore's leading nightlife and
lifestyle brand famous food
street eats will be in an interactive 24
000
square foot street food destination
available to guests and non-guests of
the resort
it's located right off the casino floor
and designed
to offer a new age dining experience
i do believe what makes us unique is the
fact that we've managed to kind of
collate these
collection of um very authentic
asian hawkers a lot of the food halls
there also also concentrate maybe more
on
um you know u.s brands right i think
here we're really bringing most most
most brands that we have actually from
from asia right so i think that's going
to be
something which is very unique and very
special very exciting well las vegas
will be its landmark destination
as this concept has never been done at
any of the other resort world locations
additional food and beverage concepts
opening at resorts world
las vegas will be announced in the
coming weeks as they are set to open
this summer looks great brian